hello I'm Peter Cook I'm the head of the
school of drama here at Carnegie Mellon
University we're sitting in the Chomsky
theater preparing a production of The
Full Monty a wonderful musical about the
transformation of a industrial city not
unlike Pittsburgh but this musical said
in Buffalo every year we do four main
stage productions in this theater this
big theater it's a fabulous theater to
be putting on big complicated
productions because we have an acting
course and the music is theater course
all under the umbrella of an acting
course so we have music theater students
and acting students we have to have
opportunities for them to show their
skills and to work on stage in big
productions so that they leave here and
they could go to Broadway or the go to
Chicago or wherever they want to go that
they will have experienced something on
the scale of what they're going to go
out and work in so this production is a
very large production it's all designed
every part of it is done by the student
labor students work on it so that can
involve in a show like Full Monty we
might have 60 or so students working on
this production 20 on stage but we've
got 40 in this great machine of this
theater this fabulous theater putting
the show together